es un mensaje urgente de pekín a todos
los gobiernos locales hay que asegurarse
de que cada gota de agua es utilizada de
forma adecuada la misión es salvar la
cosecha de otoño que es el 75 por ciento
del total anual y que está amenazada por
el verano más caliente y seco de los
últimos 60 años es una situación
delicada no solo para china sino para
todo el mundo porque china produce la
mayor parte del grano que consume y si
le faltara tendría que acudir al mercado
global en una situación ya de
estrecheces ya que otro productor
habitual como ucrania está en serios
problemas por la guerra todo el país
está afectado por la sequía pero
especialmente la provincia de sichuan
recibe el 80 por ciento de la energía de
las plantas hidroeléctricas y tanto sus
pantanos como sus ríos están en mínimos
así que las autoridades han tenido que
ordenar cortes de electricidad a la
industria que se extenderán a la
población si la situación no mejora
china tiene una necesidad urgente de
lluvias y ya ha advertido de que
retomará el uso de químicos para
arrancar el agua a las nubes no es una
práctica nueva hace años en la capital
cuando la contaminación
tendía a sólida era costumbre que se
lanzaran cohetes cargados de yoduro de
plata las nubes para limpiar aunque sólo
fuera por unas horas el cielo de pekín